RICH: Welcome to the first
Android Developer Office Hours
of the new year.
Happy new year,
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE], and any
other, or maybe Dutch.
Johan, can you jump in with a
Dutch Happy New Year for us?
JOHAN: [SPEAKING DUTCH]
RICH: [DUTCH], to
you too as well.
So happy new Android year
kicked off by CES.
As you may notice, we're joined
by Chris Banes in the
Android studio today.
CHRIS: Ta-da.
RICH: And that's because he's
the newest member of the
Android Developer Relations
team based out of London.
Welcome, Chris.
And we've got Sparky with us.
Hey, Sparky.
SPARKY: I'm here, yes.
I'm here largely to acknowledge
my departure,
since I am moving out of Android
Developer Relations
and into internal
Google projects.
I'll be doing much the same
thing as I did before, but for
inward facing stuff rather
than external.
RICH: I hope that works
out very well.
I'm sure we'll still see you
in the Android scene and
around, Sparky.
And, of course, Nick
Butcher as well.
Hey, Nick.
NICK: Hi, happy New Year.
RICH: So it's been kicked off
the new year with CES.
I guess we've seen lots and lots
of new Android stories.
Have you got any favorites
from over there
in the London office?
CHRIS: It seems to be the big
CES of big, big phones, so
lots of 1080p, 5 inch,
6 inch devices.
NICK: Can we call it a phone
if it's 6 inches?
CHRIS: Tablet, maybe?
NICK: Oh, I hate that word.
CHRIS: Yeah, it's a bad word.
SPARKY: Vizio, is that
who made that?
CHRIS: Vizio, Zed TE, Xperia,
Sony, Lenovo,
they're all up there.
NICK: It seemed like 1080p
is the new table stakes
resolution.
When you read a review of the
phone, it says 720p screen.
You go, oh.
RICH: I just want 1080p at 4.7
inches, I really don't want to
stretch to that 5 inches.
CHRIS: It's weird, because
previously, with the 720p, you
had that tablet and then
phones caught up.
Whereas now, it's phones have
gone 1080p, but tablets
haven't quite got there yet.
Obviously, you've got the Nexus
10, but most tablets are
still at the 1280.
RICH: Yeah, funnily enough I saw
one this morning on "The
Verge" that was 1,920
by 1,200, so gone
past 1080p, a 7 inch.
So maybe that's what the 7
inches are going to set.
Rather than 10 inches,
it'll be 1080p.
SPARKY: I think 2,560 is where
it's at for tablets now.
What can I say?
I'm spoiled.
NICK: That's your new year's
resolution, get it?
RICH: No, that's a good point.
With the Tegra 4, the Quad-core
A15, and the new
SnapDragons, the S800, S600, and
all those chips coming out
in the next few months, we could
definitely be seeing
those high resolutions getting
pushed around.
YOSSI: Hi, guys.
SPARKY: That said, I do have
to acknowledge that Santa
Claus was very, very
busy hauling around
Nexus 7's in my family.
RICH: Mine too.
Mine too.
Definitely, Nexus 7, a popular
gift this year.
NICK: I think one of my
stand-outs from CES, I've
seen, is Vizio and some other
manufacturers seem to be
backing off their OEM
customizations and recognizing
that stock Android has got to a
point where it's a fantastic
experience.
And you don't need to put
layers on top of it.
It just slows down upgrade
cycles and so forth.
So, for me, I think that's
a wonderful sign.
I think we're really
rounding a corner.
RICH: Yeah, it's excellent
news, isn't it?
I was hoping to see
more of that.
And goodbye, goodbye
to Cupcake.
The Android dashboard updated
last week and Cupcake has
fallen off the bottom.
I assume that means
it's less than
half of 0.1% or something.
Sorry?
NICK: And 40% of users
are on Ice Cream
Sandwich and above, right?
RICH: Yeah, over 40%
[INAUDIBLE].
And most of that is Ice
Cream Sandwich.
SPARKY: Given that Cupcake had
some noteworthy security
problems, and even the G1 was
upgradable to Donut, I never
wanted anyone to support
Cupcake anyhow.
RICH: OK, just having
browser issues.
NICK: And unfortunately, Matt's
not here because he's
at CES, lucky guy.
So what, he's probably
asleep right now.
But there's a few new
announcements
on the GTV as well.
So the ASUS device and
a new high sense
device, I think, right?
Pretty exciting.
CHRIS: The Qube looks
good, the ASUS one
looks very nice device.
Very home-orientated.
That's good.
Your big thing is Nvidia's
Project Shield, a new game
controller device.
NICK: Yeah, of course,
anyone excited?
YOSSI: That was really
cool to see.
NICK: He said it's going to get
24 hours of HD playback,
video playback.
That's got to be a good sign
for the Tegra 4, I hope.
I think, didn't they say it's a
new 28 nanometer processor?
CHRIS: Also, it's
in a controller.
You can keep a bigger
battery anyway.
NICK: Yeah, I guess so.
CHRIS: So that might be why.
It's also not a big screen.
It's about 4 inches.
YOSSI: Yeah, it's still a big
screen for a controller you
just put in your hands.
CHRIS: Oh yeah, definitely.
SPARKY: But you know they're
just going to use that
increased efficiency just to
give you a smaller battery and
chipping devices.
NICK: Yeah, probably.
It's a good thing, right?
I guess they're all having the
4-PLUS-1 cores now as well,
aren't they?
So they're having the low crowd
core, which tips over
when you're not really taxing it
and then spins up the high
performance one, so I think I
would like to see more focus
on battery life this year.
RICH: Absolutely.
What else was it?
It wasn't just the--
I can't remember what
I was going to say.
Just skip that one.
NICK: That's hardware, right?
The CES, so we're on the Android
developer on the
software side of things.
We had an exciting blog post
yesterday talking about some
new authentication steps
that you can do.
RICH: Yeah, you can use GMS Core
to authenticate against
your own back-end servers
now, endpoints,
things that like that.
I haven't delved into
it myself yet.
NICK: I'm pretty excited
about it.
I think it relieves a need to
handle things like usernames
and passwords in your app, and
still be sure of who you're
talking to.
So I think this is really,
really, awesome.
CHRIS: Yeah, it's a nice
way of doing it.
Because having to get users
to register and login, it
disrupts the user flow.
So anything to make our apps
as seamless as possible is
always a good thing.
YOSSI: Is there a demo app
for that to see the flow
and stuff like that?
Or is it just a blog post?
CHRIS: It's a blog post, but it
goes through the whole flow
using the Google
Play services.
YOSSI: Oh, I will look
it up later.
CHRIS: Yeah, it's on Google+
and on the blog site.
NICK: Yeah, top of the
blog right now.
RICH: OK, welcome Guiseppe
as well, from Italy.
GUISEPPE: Thank you very much.
Happy New Year to everybody.
RICH: Happy New Year.
And Lucas, as well.
Hey there.
Happy New Year, Lucas.
OK, does anyone in the Hangout
have a question before we jump
into the 14 questions
we have lined up in
the moderators today?
I wonder if Andrew Kelly
put all of them in.
SPARKY: Not all, but
maybe a third.
RICH: OK.
JOHAN: I posed a question
in the moderator, guys.
I've ran into an issue where
my app is causing a force
close on a Sony Xperia device.
And it turns out the Sony Xperia
framework is referring
to a resource ID, which I have
also defined in my app.
So it looks like it's, I don't
know, using an app resource ID
or something.
Have you encountered such things
where device failures--
RICH: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHAN: Yeah.
RICH: No, I mean, it's a very
large pool of resource ID's.
And the chances of them clashing
are very small.
But I guess it is possible
that they could clash.
I mean, they are generated at
random in the resources.java
file, right?
JOHAN: Yeah, but in this case,
it's for setting the font
scroll thump drawable, which
apparently Sony is using its
own skin or theme or whatever.
But still, I've read a post
by Dianne Hackborn,
which states the--
what's it called-- the 7F, the
first two x numbers in the
resource identifier
are for apps only.
So is it then a block by Sony
using, I don't know,
hard-coded resource
identifiers?
Or how did it get generated
getting into their framework?
Has anybody encountered
that with other OSes?
RICH: I haven't no.
But if Sony are building on top
of the Android framework
and putting their own apps in,
maybe they're not using the
reserved resource IDs
for their own apps.
JOHAN: Oh, OK, that could be.
YOSSI: I think you can
do a workaround by
using public IDs XMLs.
And generate your own IDs and
set the IDs and the XML to be
sequentially added.
And I think that should do a
workaround on all devices.
Because on the public
XML, you can define
IDs you want to expose.
And if you want to expose
them, then the system
generates different linkage
or something, I'm not
sure where it is.
I just read about it
a few years ago.
NICK: So I think I saw a
blog post about this.
Weren't you saying it was only
happening when they introduced
ActionBar Sherlock into it?
JOHAN: Yeah, but I don't
know if that's the--
NICK: Well, that makes me think
it's something to do
with theme, perhaps.
Because if you're using the
Sherlock themes, then they may
be trying to theme some
of the attributes.
And if they're just trying to
alias them to underlying
resources and Sony's changed
something, then--
JOHAN: Yeah, but there's a blog
post about that as well.
And then you have to move
that specific attribute.
But it's still attributed
to a values dash
v11 resource folder.
And then I think you're out of
the loop, not clashing those
on older Android OS devices.
So I'm not sure if it's
ActionBar Sherlock specific.
Because in my view, it's a Sony
framework resource, it's
apps list view.
So it could be in
their framework.
Or it could be in their app,
like Rich was saying, in one
of their apps, I don't know.
So yeah, it pops up with
ActionBar Sherlock, that's
definitely true, Nick.
But I'm not sure if that
is the real issue here.
RICH: Well, it sounds
very bad.
If it's a resource that you
can use inside your
application that they're
providing that's terrible for
them to use a 7F ID
for it, isn't it?
[INAUDIBLE] will clash, right?
Maybe just email me
the details of it.
I know that Dianne knows
about it now, as well.
And we'll see if we can send
it off to our Sony partner
manager and see what happens.
JOHAN: OK, will do.
RICH: Do you know which
device it was on?
JOHAN: Yup.
RICH: Is it a new firmware
or old firmware?
JOHAN: Old firmware, 2.3.4.
RICH: OK, but it's already
been reported and fixed.
JOHAN: Yeah, that's what
I'm afraid of.
But then you still have to
have workarounds for this
particular device--
RICH: What a crazy case.
JOHAN: Affecting all
Sony devices.
OK, that should--
OK, curious.
OK, thanks guys.
RICH: But it would good to find
out the details because
it could affect everyone.
Are Nick and Chris live?
NICK: We're back.
We dropped out, but
we're back.
RICH: OK, any other--
CHRIS: [INAUDIBLE] muted?
Oops.
RICH: Any other questions
from the Hangout?
Or should we jump into
this moderator?
Sounds like we're going to
jump into the moderator.
SPARKY: You already did, because
Johan's question was
one of our moderator
questions.
RICH: Absolutely, it's always
nice when people who are going
to ask questions in Hangout
put them in the moderator
first, though, so we get a
chance to pre-read them, not
that I did.
It looks like you've already
had a look through some of
these, Sparky.
Do you want to jump on one?
SPARKY: Oh, I could.
I didn't have much to say
about this first one.
Jamie says, "when using a
multi-autotext view, I process
the list when user selects
an item by clicking.
But I also want to detect new
items added manually, ones not
on the list, and do the same
process, as it's one words
when user press space or
punctuation, et cetera." He
goes on to say, "I used
KeyListener, but this only
works with Android IME options
set to something, which is
annoying, as in landscape on
smaller devices, it fills the
screen, gives a button.
I either want to stop it
filling the screen or
not have it be set.
Am I doing it completely
wrong?"
I don't have a lot to contribute
on that one.
I don't have experience with
that particular control.
Any of you guys work with
multi-autotext view before?
CHRIS: I have, but I'm trying
to work out what
he's trying to do.
I might skip that one and
do it after I have
another read through.
SPARKY: Well, we can always come
back to that one later.
Should we--
RICH: I mean, the IME always
fills the screen landscape in
landscape mode, right?
That's just the default
behavior?
CHRIS: You can have variety,
though, from what I remember.
RICH: You can indeed have
variety and use your own
custom one.
SPARKY: Well, here's
an easy one.
Shivano from Egypt says, "are
there any news regarding
augmented reality APIs for
Android camera?" I know of
some third party augmented
reality APIs.
Most of the augmented reality
stacks have one, like Junaio's
got one, and I think Layar's
got one, and Wikitude.
But I don't know of any actually
from Android itself.
NICK: That's definitely new
in the developer space.
I wouldn't expect to see
SDs, I know that.
SPARKY: [INAUDIBLE]
at some point in the future.
I mean, taking off my "knows
anything" hat and putting on
my "wild speculation" hat, I'm
thinking that some sort AR
will probably have to go with
Google Glass, otherwise what
good would it be for?
RICH: Maybe, but maybe they
would also use to use AR
Toolkit or something.
We could divert the entire
Android engineering's team
resources to building an AR
library if we wanted.
But there's some excellent ones
out there already that
many apps and games are being
built on top of and
professional software.
Just have a search for it, hit
up AR Toolkit or something.
It's a complex area to
be delving into.
SPARKY: Of course, there's many
different kinds of AR,
too, right?
I mean, there's real
world stuff
overlaid on top of video.
But then there's also actually
looking at codes and specific
recognized items.
So there's the geo-stuff, and
then there's also the image
processing stuff.
CHRIS: Andrew Kelly's put a good
question in saying, "with
fragments, what's the
correct way to
move from one to another?
As in, one to two to three
to four for a data entry?
And then the fourth fragment, or
pressing back?" You want to
go back to the start rather than
going back through the
fragments, so there's a
wizard touch thing.
The best way to do that, I'd
say, is each time you add a
fragment, add a backstack ID.
So usually you add an ID, and
so it can be any string you
want, really.
And then, when the user
does press back--
it's probably better
to have a button,
actually, saying finished.
And then when they press
finish, you can call--
what's the call?
NICK: Yeah, fragment manager,
or something.
CHRIS: I can't remember.
There's a method call which
takes you back to that
particular ID, so you remove
all the fragments from the
backstack and you go back
to the original ID.
You can also do it with the back
button by not adding add
to backstack when you
add a fragment.
SPARKY: I'm not entirely
sure if I agree
with that user flow.
I think, either you go with
the paradigm that says
fragments don't do backstack.
Say you're reading through your
emails, if you have a
navigation pane and a detail
pane, usually you don't stick
those on the backstack.
Or they do, in which case, maybe
you should go backwards
through the sequence of input
dialogues or whatever.
I don't really agree with
changing the behavior just
because the user's completed
all the input.
I would usually interpret the
back button, in an input
scenario like that, as saying
cancel, forget it all.
Either meaning, go back and
correct the previous page, or,
I suppose, just wipe
the whole mess.
I don't know.
I'm not really liking changing
it just because
it's on the last page.
RICH: Personally, if I was going
to do a wizard flow, I'd
use Roman's wizard sample.
Just use that, because he's
put a lot of effort into
making a wizard flow that looks
nice and works well.
And you can go through stage by
stage without being able to
skip stages and all
that good stuff.
So I'd probably just let Roman
do the work and go and grab
his wizard flow sample.
SPARKY: Plus one for not
reinventing the wheel.
NICK: Yeah, that's at
code.google.com/
p/romannurik-code.
YOSSI: I just wanted to add
something about what Sparky
said about the flow for the
fragments and don't use the
backstack for everything.
If we want to show the user a
tutorial and we want him to go
back to the main screen of the
app, then that's the best use
case for not using the backstack
or overriding the
simple behavior for the
backstack for fragments.
SPARKY: Yeah, that does seem to
be the obvious control to
use for closing out
a tutorial.
Either that, or maybe
the up chevron.
NICK: I'd want a explicit skip
button in any tutorial.
SPARKY: Yeah, that's
a fair point too.
Although I'm actually pretty
OK with using back to just
close out a tutorial.
I don't feel the need for
a skip button there.
NICK: I feel if it's the first
thing I see when I launch the
app, it feels like back would
close the app to me.
CHRIS: You don't know
something's behind it.
YOSSI: No, but I think the best
use case is what Sparky
said, just back from the first
screen of the tutorial puts
you back into the main
screen of the app.
CHRIS: But only if you've showed
the user the main bit
of the app first.
Otherwise they don't know what's
behind the tutorial.
YOSSI: So the best use case to
show a tutorial then, I'll do
something like, first
screen the user sees
the tutorial screen.
And instead of a skip, the home
navigation will get you
back to the main screen of the
app from any screen you're in
the tutorial.
Say you have eight screens for
the tutorial, every time you
press on the home navigation you
go back to the home screen
for the app.
NICK: Yeah, I'm fine with the
back button closing the
tutorial and taking you
back to the launch
screen of the app.
I think it should do
that, in fact.
But I also would like a skip
button just because there's no
obvious avoidance
for going back.
SPARKY: I could see how maybe
this is a case where you want
to do different behavior for
your tablet and your phone UI.
Your phone UI fills the whole
screen, in which case, maybe
having a skip button is the
obvious thing to do.
But if you have a tablet UI,
maybe your tutorial is just a
little inset dialogue, in which
case it's obvious that
there's an app behind there,
and then that could just
dismiss it.
NICK: That works.
CHRIS: Sounds good.
YOSSI: That's nice.
NICK: Cool, all right, should we
go to the next question in
the moderator?
Redier--
I guess I'm probably not
saying that right--
is asking if there's any
pointers for implementing a
chips type UI on pre-ICS
devices, and are there any
proper libraries available?
So the chips UI, I guess, is
the UI we use in Gmail and
Messaging and so forth, so
that, as you enter a
recipient's name, and then you
pick one from the list, it
turns it into a nice little
box with their name and a
little avatar on them.
It's quite a nice little UI to
echo that they've understood
what you meant.
And to that end, I would say
probably look into the SMS
application, MMS.get, which is
open source so that's going to
be probably your best best.
He explicitly asked about
pre-ICS, so I'm wondering if
there's anything in there
that's dependent on it.
I'm not sure.
I'd have to have a look
and see if there's
dependencies on UI stuff.
Anyone know of any other--
CHRIS: Can't think
of anything.
NICK: There's a nice answer
as well if someone's--
oh no, it's himself.
He's saying he's started
creating his own one.
But I guess he's wondering
if there's any
better sample codes.
But I would take a look
at the MMS app.
No one else got any
experience here?
CHRIS: It looks like something
about Track Anywhere, because
he's using autocomplete text
view, which is what you'll
more than likely need.
NICK: That's what I'd do.
Any other questions live
from the room?
We've got new joiners.
Ah, there you are.
Is that Redier?
It's your question.
Hi, welcome.
Have you had a look
at the MMS app?
REDIER: I haven't yet, no.
But it works fairly well.
It's a bit misty,
but it works.
You use low CPU spec, low RAM
spec, the bulk on reference
design devices, so it needs to
be as lightweight as possible.
And this one works well.
NICK: Yeah, from your
description, it sounds like
you're absolutely on
the right track.
RICH: I just saw one--
sorry--
I just saw a question in the
moderator that says that video
calendar dot getInstance and
getYear on it, it's returning
2012, if you're on Android 4.1.2
and 2013 if you're on
Android 4.2, which is crazy.
Obviously I have no idea why.
But it should definitely be
raised as a bug, if it is
true, with repro steps.
And more details, are you
running one on an emulator and
one on a device?
And maybe the clock is set
wrong on one of them.
I don't know.
The clock on an emulator
maybe?
But it seems very strange.
I would have thought we'd have
heard about it if it was
always the case that the
Calendar classes in Android
where returning the
wrong year on 4.1.
Anybody heard anything
about that before?
CHRIS: That is odd.
RICH: Then again, if you told
me that we were missing
December last year, I would have
laughed and said, hey.
Definitely check the
bug tracker.
This is from Etienne.
And I might actually go and try
it myself, because that's
just crazy if it's true.
NICK: He says, both
are on a device.
CHRIS: Does it?
RICH: Oh yeah, he's commented
on his own thing saying both
are on a device.
And the clock's set right on the
device, on both of them?
NICK: [INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI: Maybe a different
time zone?
[LAUGHTER]
RICH: Very close to the
new year when he
was doing it, maybe?
SPARKY: Etienne, this
sounds familiar.
I think this is someone we've
heard from before.
RICH: "Day getYear returns a
value that the results are
subtracting 1900 from the year
that contains or begins with
the instance in time represented
by this date
object as interpreted in
the local time zone.
This is deprecated for
a good reason."
YOSSI: Y2K again?
RICH: Thanks for the
rapid response.
So maybe, actually, this is
a known issue and you
shouldn't be using--
I mean, it's documented
in Java Docs, and
JDK 6 is Java Doc.
But I can't see the
same documentation
in the Android docs.
YOSSI: Or in JD.
RICH: I wonder.
Weird.
YOSSI: Johan needs coffee.
CHRIS: Some of the values return
at zero index and some
are actual values.
So month is zero indexed,
from what I remember.
So it's day, the day of
month, and year isn't.
RICH: Anything else from
inside the Hangout?
YOSSI: Yeah, can I send
you a YouTube video
to see for a second?
RICH: Yeah, put it in
the group chat.
Go for it.
Is this kittens or something
or "Gangnam Style"?
YOSSI: No, I think
it's a good--
RICH: You've got a slide
bar orientation
sliding in and out.
YOSSI: Yeah, the sliding
menus to show
that you have swiping--
RICH: Like a tutorial?
YOSSI: Yeah, what do
you think about it?
Is this good way to persuade
users to use the sliding menu
or use the slide or
swipe feature?
RICH: Yeah, I've seen a few of
them now, actually, which, on
first run of the application,
they force that slide just to
show the user that it's there.
Maybe our UI designer
can comment on that.
Can you see the video, Nick?
NICK: Yeah, we're just
looking at it now.
So you have a little hint?
Come on, click me.
RICH: Nice that the ActionBar
is there.
And it's all very
smooth, anyway.
YOSSI: First of all,
I love the app--
[NOISE]
CHRIS: Everyone mute Etienne.
SPARKY: Oh, we have Etienne
in the Hangout.
Did we just talk about
your question?
ETIENNE: Actually,
you just did.
I don't know if we got
a response, though.
NICK: Is it the Calendar
bug issue?
ETIENNE: Yeah, it's
the Calendar bug.
NICK: Yeah, we have no idea.
We'll have to go and try
and repro it, I guess.
ETIENNE: Sure.
How do I go about that,
if I'm filing bug?
NICK: Actually, you go
to b.android.com.
And all the steps
are right there.
ETIENNE: Oh, OK.
Yeah, I've never
done it before.
NICK: Yeah, the key is just to
have a simple test case that
we can use to replicate it.
ETIENNE: OK, I was looking--
because you said check the set
time on the Nexus S, and I
don't know where to see
potentially the date.
And the date's set to
the current date,
January 9 of this year.
RICH: But you're not sure
what the year's set to?
ETIENNE: Well, I would believe
it's set to the current year.
But there's nothing to
suggest that it's--
RICH: If you go into Menu,
Settings, then Date and Time.
It's worth double-checking
before raising the bug.
ETIENNE: Yeah, date and time.
RICH: You don't know how
much I hope this is
going to say 2012.
YOSSI: 1992.
ETIENNE: That's strange.
I guess my date was
set to 2012.
Thank you.
It could have something to do
with I took the SIM card out.
And placed it into my Nexus
4, because I just got it.
So that could be the issue.
The time isn't synced
up because of the
SIM card being removed.
NICK: [INAUDIBLE]
has set the right date and
month, but not the right year.
YOSSI: If you check the
automatic network update time
and you log in to Wi-Fi or
something, then it goes to the
time servers and updates
according to the time zone.
ETIENNE: Yeah, I think I'm
testing on a device that's
without a SIM card.
So it's not really
a real scenario.
So I guess I shouldn't
account for that.
NICK: Listen, we should go
back to Yossi's question,
because we interrupted.
RICH: Yes, absolutely.
NICK: So your question was
basically, is it cool to use
some kind of animation to hint
at how you interact?
YOSSI: Yes.
NICK: So where do you envision
showing that?
Just on first run?
YOSSI: Basically, on
two occasions.
On first run because we're
going to do a UI change.
The example I posted was
specific for swiping.
But I'm talking generally on
all the swiping, double
tapping, you name it, whatever
gesture you want us
to do on your app.
I'm talking about making a
simple two seconds demo of the
gesture and showing that to the
user as here you can click
on me, here you can scratch me,
here you can kick me, I
don't know, whatever.
NICK: Yeah, generally I'm OK
with using some kind of
animation as an affordance,
essentially, to say, this is
how you interact with me.
I think what you need to be wary
of is getting annoying.
So showing it every time
might become annoying.
I saw some iterations of the
YouTube application, for
example, when they moved to the
sliding draw, similar to
this application.
It used to open with that and
then the menu eye would fold
in, just hint at it.
And we played around with
some iterations of that.
And I think it was decided that
it was just unnecessary,
that the sliding in menu
was becoming a
well-known pattern now.
And that it was an unnecessary
road bump to go over in order
to get to what you really want
to, which is the content.
I think as these introductions
become more and more popular--
some of the top applications out
there are using it, like
YouTube, G+, Facebook, things
like this are using these
slidey menus, some with with
swipe, some without--
that people are getting
used to it.
And it becomes unnecessary.
But yeah, generally if you have
gestures that are hard,
that there aren't any natural
way to hint that it's
available, that you do need to
provide either some tutorial
or some way to bootstrap the
user's mental model already.
So yeah, I'm cool with that,
as long as you try to only
show it at first, a couple of
times, or something like that.
YOSSI: Some apps basically use
overlay on the layout with
some arrows, and pointers,
and text.
And I think I prefer this way,
the user sees the real
interaction with the UI, instead
of an image showing
with text and stuff.
CHRIS: I think it totally
depends on the interaction.
So if there's something where
you have to swipe, showing the
user is probably better.
There's a good library called
showcase view, which is based
off the launches.
So that's where you could
put buttons and
something you have to click.
I personally like showing the
user small interactions.
So in some of the personal
source libraries I write, I
always add an easy way for the
developer to a show demo.
So yeah, I personally like it.
LUCAS: This is actually--
can you hear me?
This is actually one of the
reasons I'm not entirely
convinced about this pattern.
Because it leads to trial
and error, in general.
Suppose that there are lots of
top apps using it, but then
you always wonder if
it's there or not.
So we will always have to do
something like this, show the
user that it's there,
and then you do it.
So this is one of the reasons I
didn't like the menu button
approach from previous
Android releases.
Because some apps just-- the
hardware button, I mean--
some apps just didn't have it.
So you had to try to see if
there's something there.
And for any pattern that you
have to try to see if it's
there, it's a sign that there's
something that needs
to be improved.
Either a standard hint that it's
there, like the app menu,
it's the three dot thing.
It's there.
You know you click.
You see something.
If it's not there, there's
no option.
But with sliding menus, you have
to try, or you have to
give a hint.
It's just a sign that there's
something that
is not ready yet.
YOSSI: No, on your ActionBar, on
the top you can say that if
you have an app error, or maybe
a change of the home
logo, then you have
a sliding menu.
LUCAS: But I mean, maybe
if we changed the icon.
It's just that I think it's
abusing the standard behavior
because right now it's going
up in the hierarchy.
And I mean, you might argue that
a sliding-in menu is the
upper, or the top level node
in your hierarchy.
But it's not really, is it?
RICH: When people do a slide-in
menu from the left
and to the right--
NICK: Somewhat tricky.
SPARKY: Doesn't the design site
say that the slide-in
menu can only be at
the top level?
YOSSI: Yeah, it's like an
activity group of some sort,
because you can refer to it as
the root holder for all the
other actions you can do
on your application.
LUCAS: Yeah, and the other thing
I dislike about it is,
when you have such a big space
for options, I think people
will tend to overload
in terms of options.
So you just have too many nodes
into a hierarchy just
because you have space for it.
And if you see things like
Facebook, it has a huge thing.
Google+, you see it in a smarter
way because it uses
the space for showing more
notifications, so that's fine.
But still it's tempting, because
you have this huge,
infinite vertical space
for adding options.
And in the case of mobile apps,
I don't think that's a
good thing to do.
Constraints are a good
thing on mobile,
in general, I think.
NICK: Yeah, we dropped out, so
we might have missed some of
the conversation.
But we're back now.
I think two things I want
to touch with that.
Firstly, I think the gesture
is like a power user thing.
That's how I think of it.
I think you need to have some
onscreen affordance, like you
were saying, that you can't
have this, you have
to try it and see.
I think you need to have some
onscreen affordance.
So our preference would
be to use the up
carrot to disclose it.
That's our guidelines.
Some people use the [INAUDIBLE]
menu, which is
gaining some traction as well.
I very much see the bezel swipe,
or the swiping, as a
secondary way of launching.
So in that way, I'm not so
bothered if people don't know
about it because it's more about
once you hit menu, the
primary way of opening it, the
button, and you see it slide
out, that is your hint.
That is your animation.
That's the cue that this
thing moves that way.
And if you swipe it and discover
it, that you can do
it with your finger rather than
hitting the button, then
that's power user
bonus, in a way.
As long as there is one obvious
on screen button,
which is the default way to open
it, I think that's the
most important thing.
And for the second thing I was
going to say is about the
dumping ground.
I very prefer if the slide-in
menu just is used for
navigation.
I see it as an alternative to
the drop down navigation you
might see on Google Maps, or if
there's more tabs that you
might want to have on screen.
I see it as a direct replacement
for that.
I'd rather not see it combined
with actions.
Some people start putting
extra things in there.
And I think, in a way, G+'s
notifications almost fall into
that bucket for me.
I'd rather see it's just about a
navigation thing rather than
oh, I've got some extra
space, I'll dump some
extra stuff in there.
CHRIS: Yeah, I agree
with that.
I'd prefer it if the Google+
version showed just your
unread notifications, rather
than all of them.
And then if you click on the
unread notification, it'll
take you to a list.
That would be the way I'd do
it if I was the developer.
SPARKY: Teasing Google+
aside, empty space is
important for layout.
CHRIS: Going back to what you
said about dumping ground,
sure, that's up to the app
developer to make their app as
cognitively easy to
use as possible.
So you should design your
app so that it has--
NICK: A structure.
CHRIS: Yeah, well, a
structure, yeah.
Three or four, or less, main
sections to your app.
And the user can then delve
deeper if they want to.
So that's up to the app
developer to do that.
NICK: I think the problem is
when you get to apps like
Facebook and Google+, they're
such huge apps.
They're basically like
an OS, in a way.
They offer so many functions.
There are messaging.
There's newsfeeds.
There's photos.
There's communities.
There's so much going on.
LUCAS: There's a reason why
Facebook is splitting their
app into different functions,
the camera,
Messenger, and all that.
And I think that's probably
the right approach.
I wouldn't do this huge
thing in one place.
CHRIS: What I've got from
Facebook is that the reason
they've got separate apps
is so they can test
stuff out on users.
So Messenger, all the stuff
that's in Messenger has been
backported to the
Facebook app.
So it's the same code base now
in the actual Facebook app for
messages as it is
for Messenger.
Same with the camera stuff.
I do agree with you.
I think with Facebook
that they have
overlaid the sliding menu.
They have got all these
separate sections.
NICK: Or layers, right?
You can go back within the
sliding menu, right?
CHRIS: Yeah, but they've also
got groups, and then you've
got a sub-list of your groups.
Whereas, for me, it should be
just one group item where you
can click and delve in.
RICH: OK, maybe we should take
one from the G+ stream now,
instead of from the Hangout
or the Moderator.
Alessandro Capra is asking,
"I've made an application,
which is a music quiz.
And it requires registration
from the user with username
and password and other details,
should I provide a
privacy policy?"
And the answer is, yes.
Yes, you should.
Our developer distribution
agreement in section 4.3 says
that if users are providing
you or your product with
access to username, details,
products, email addresses,
personal information, then you
must make the users aware that
the information will be
available to your products.
And you must provide a legally
adequate privacy notice and
protection for those users.
So if you don't put a privacy
policy in and you are
requesting personal details,
then it may be grounds to get
your application suspended
from the Play Store.
You'll be violating the
DDA if you don't.
So definitely, please do put a
privacy policy in if you're
requesting personal
information.
Also, there's a slot in the
developer console at the
bottom of your store listing
where you can link to your
privacy policy online.
So users can see it before
they've gone and downloaded
the application and installed
it and given you
some of their details.
Because you may be getting some
details off the handset
automatically, so it's quite
good if you can put the link
in to the privacy policy.
I know that the latest version
2 of the publisher site
doesn't let you publish your app
until you've either put a
privacy policy in or explicitly
told the system
that you're not going
to have one.
So it became mandatory to do the
flag one way or the other
in the latest version.
Hopefully that answers your
question, Alessandro.
CHRIS: Looks like Guiseppe's
got a question.
RICH: Has Guiseppe got
a question, or is
he on a phone call?
CHRIS: No, he's got
a question.
RICH: Guiseppe?
GUISEPPE: Yes.
Well, I have a question about
In-app Billing version number
three, and especially about
the local caching.
I would like to understand how
this local caching work, if
the local caching mean that
the information about the
purchaser are riding inside some
database or inside some
other protection mode.
Because in the documentation
I didn't find
nothing about that.
The question is because I want
to understand what happens
exactly when, for example, a
user buys some item using the
In-app system.
And after we make the refund to
the users for any reason,
I'd like to know if the local
caching would take into
account that the purchase has
been refunded and then will be
not useful anymore for
the application?
NICK: How do you mean refunded
in an In-app purchase?
Do you mean through--
GUISEPPE: I mean, for example,
that the user writes to us and
ask for the refund,
not that he can
make the refund himself.
Because this is not possible,
as everybody knows.
NICK: Exactly correct.
I don't think the app Billing
API has the concept of
refunding, so I doubt--
RICH: I don't think
it does either.
No, I agree.
So if you're trying to refund
an In-app Billing item, then
they still own it.
You've just given them
their money back.
GUISEPPE: So when I will use the
method to get purchases,
the purchase will
be not refreshed
in the local history?
RICH: No, I think the user will
still own that item that
they've purchased through
In-app Billing.
But I will have look,
just in case.
CHRIS: Yeah, I don't think it
matters if it's cached.
GUISEPPE: In the documentation,
I didn't find
any useful about this.
NICK: Yeah, I don't think
caching changes anything here.
I think, even without the
caching, if you refresh it
from the server it will still
say, yes, the user has
purchased item.
Like I say, I don't think the
In-app purchase API has any
concept of refund.
RICH: Slightly contrary
to that, the
documentation does say that.
In-app Billing doesn't allow
users to request refunds.
But if you refund them through
Google Checkout, Google Play
receives a refund notification
from check out and sends a
refund notification to
the application.
GUISEPPE: That is good.
RICH: In which case, as long as
the device is connected to
the network, the local cache
will be updated straight away,
and your application will
receive the refund
notification.
GUISEPPE: That's very good.
And do you know, Richard,
if the local caching is
maintained by some SQL like
database or any way?
RICH: I don't know where
they keep the data.
I don't know.
GUISEPPE: Because I am thinking
if we have just to
come back to [INAUDIBLE]
license [INAUDIBLE], or we
have also to come back to
[INAUDIBLE] the people that we
try to write some rove inside
the database.
RICH: If it is a database,
my guess is
it's quite well encrypted.
I doubt there's anything on
there that's easy to attack.
I wouldn't be worried about
our side of it.
I just put a link in
the chat window as
well to handling refunds.
And that then links off and
shows you the flow.
GUISEPPE: What exactly is the
reason why in In-app items are
not refundable?
Why Google decide that?
RICH: Well, because the user
may have already spent it.
They may be buying calling
credit, things like that, on
your In-app Billing.
And then they may make
a phone call and
then refund the credit.
If we had a 15 minute refund
window, they could totally
abuse that for In-app Billing,
because we don't know what
they've just purchased
from you.
If they can consume it in the
first 15 minutes and then
refund it, they could just
continue doing that and have
infinite free service
on your service.
GUISEPPE: Correct.
RICH: I mean, app developers
expected applications for that
first 15 minutes.
But for In-app Billing,
we don't know
what you've just sold.
So it's not reasonable.
NICK: Cool, all right, we've got
10 minutes to go, should
we go back to the Moderator and
pick up any more questions?
Who's got the Moderator
at hand?
Do you have that?
Dave S. In London says, "I'm
working on improving the
testing of my apps.
Right now I test on a few
devices that run using Monkey.
I started adding some unit tests
as well, but I'm not
sure how to far to
go with them.
Are there any other good
testing methods?
How did you test
Friendcaster?"
Let's see, this isn't
a very good answer.
But we didn't as such.
Well, I did.
I spent a lot of
time using it.
So that was my main test.
And I used it a helluva lot.
But in terms of formal testing,
there wasn't a whole
lot done, just because it
was made by myself.
And I had to spend more
developing than testing.
RICH: Yeah, my answer was--
CHRIS: That was about
it, really.
We did a bit of Monkey stuff
because it's easy
and cheap to do.
Unit testing's, it's
hard to do anyway.
But you can only really do
proper unit testing on utility
casting, because that's
the easiest to do.
If you're going to start doing
UI testing, it becomes very
hard very quickly.
NICK: So there's the UI
automator tool now, which has
been launched, which is
an interesting tool.
It also helps you make sure
you add all your content
descriptions and stuff,
which is a good thing.
Johan, any other advice
on testing tools?
I know you're a fan of these.
JOHAN: No, no, no.
No, I'm mighty difficult
as well.
I'm currently writing an
app using a network
and it needs a server.
And I'm dependent
on that server.
And so I'm not using Robo.
RICH: Yeah, Etienne has
just linked to a--
JOHAN: I use unit
testing a lot.
But I'm not into user interface
automatic testing
yet for this app.
RICH: You know, there's services
out there as well,
Testdroid and other such cloud
services where you can record
scripts and send them
up and get all the
results back again.
If it's a personal project, I
test on an HTC Desire, the
Nexus 4, 7, and 10.
And if it works on those, I just
put it out there along
with a link to the bug tracker,
and hope that people
file bugs before
I make it live.
CHRIS: Did everyone see the blog
post yesterday by Android
developers saying if you've
got a Nexus 10 or other
high-res device you can call a
couple of ADB commands and you
can emulate pretty much any
device specification, in terms
of display?
RICH: Yeah, basically, if you
own the highest resolution
device that's available, then
you can test every single
resolution.
CHRIS: Pretty handy.
RICH: No, it's not just
for the Nexus 10.
It's for whatever the
highest resolution
device is at any time.
The Nexus 7 I imagine to run
the same ADB commands.
The Motorola Xoom did as well.
I'm not sure of those yet.
I've never tried it
on a Nexus 4.
I guess it does as
well, though.
CHRIS: Yeah, it will.
RICH: But you can set the
resolution to anything smaller
than that for matching the
native resolution.
CHRIS: You can set the screen
size as well, so so you can
change it to normal,
large, extra large.
[INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY: Once upon a time, didn't
it require root to use
that command?
A few versions back?
CHRIS: What, ADB?
ADB runs fine as you're
a normal user.
SPARKY: Not ADB, but
specifically the display emulation?
ETIENNE: I have a question.
Have you guys played around
with the overdraw?
It's part of the newest
Jellybean, if you go to
developer settings--
NICK: Yeah, I left it
on for a week once.
And it was really interesting if
you leave it on for a while
and see what apps are doing.
ETIENNE: Yeah, I noticed you're
allowed to, I think,
select an app to debug.
But you can't select any
app, it's only a
certain list of apps.
Anyway, I turned it on.
And I was noticing it was
explaining the overdraw.
But to disable it,
I turned it off.
And it looked like it was still
displaying on not only
the app I set, but
some other apps.
The only way to get rid of it
was to turn off the device.
NICK: No, basically the setting,
if you have overdraw
turned on, it will be caching
on the start up.
So you'll just have to kill
the app and re-start it.
ETIENNE: Oh, OK, I
didn't know that.
I thought you could just turn
the setting off and then--
NICK: No, and it's on put
for the whole device.
You don't turn it on for
a particular app.
You turn it on for the device.
If it's not working for certain
apps, it's because
they're not using the hardware
acceleration rendering framework.
They must explicitly be turning
it off somehow.
So that's the only time
you wouldn't see
the overdraw stuff.
But yeah, you need to just kill
the app, turn it on, run
the apps you want to do,
then turn it off,
kill the app again.
And you're good.
ETIENNE: Gotcha, yeah.
I was just doing a hard
boot, or reboot.
RICH: That would certainly
do it as well.
SPARKY: I'm wondering if
maybe there was some
misunderstanding on what
the set app for
debugging setting was for.
I assumed that was more just
for connecting up to an ADB
debugger when you're
on the device.
I've never actually used
that setting, have
you guys used it?
RICH: In the manifest, turning
debuggable on and off.
NICK: No, there's a thing
in the debug--
RICH: How does this [INAUDIBLE]
which app is going
to be debugged?
NICK: I've not used that.
SPARKY: I mean, I don't think
it's for targeting these on
device diagnostics.
I think that's for specifically
what the remote
debugger is going to attach to
on your device, like you're
specifically trying
to debug an app
you're writing, I assume.
ETIENNE: Yeah, by default
it says, no debug
applications set.
But you can choose only from a
small list of applications.
CHRIS: I'm guessing apps that
have Android debuggable equals
true in the manifest.
ETIENNE: Oh, that's
probably true.
Because the app I'm working
on is debug true.
RICH: So it lets you debug apps
that you haven't written
yourself maybe?
SPARKY: Possibly.
RICH: I don't know.
Perhaps [INAUDIBLE] something
will find out.
CHRIS: I'll look in the source
code, see if I just--
NICK: Use the source.
ETIENNE: I just had
a question.
I know from reading on a lot of
different blogs, they say
that the MMS, SMS content
provider is not really open
source, or it's not really
publicly available.
RICH: No, not at all.
ETIENNE: So if you can't really
rely on that being a
way to grab things like MMS or
SMS saved on your phone, is
there an alternative?
Or is that the only way
to go about it?
NICK: Correct.
There's documented APIs for SMS
and MMS document APIs for
the incoming and stuff.
So you can register for
the incoming ones
and purchase those.
But as for the actual content
provider, it's much like
Calendar used to be pre-ICS.
They're undocumented, but
they're in the code.
So use at your own risk.
ETIENNE: Yeah, I know I'm
using it at my own risk.
But I'm wondering
how frequently
does that get updated?
I heard the paths of the MMS
SMS DB is different on
different devices.
I don't know if that's--
NICK: It's kind of
the whole point.
It's not documented,
so it could, and
probably has, changed.
ETIENNE: Manufacturers
can change that path?
CHRIS: If they wish too.
NICK: They're free to change.
ETIENNE: So the only way to
really feel comfortable about
using it is to test it
on a lot of different
manufacturers.
RICH: Absolutely, yeah.
Yeah, read new SMSes come in.
Just start from the current
time and build up
your SMS from now.
But try to read all the previous
SMSes and do things
with those.
Then it's not a happy
place to be.
ETIENNE: I'm wondering is
there a way to emulate
different manufacturer phones?
CHRIS: No.
ETIENNE: No.
RICH: No, Samsung--
ETIENNE: Got to buy
a bunch of phones?
RICH: While testing online
service, a Samsung developer--
what's it called?
Maybe it's just called
Samsung Developer.
You can use devices there online
and check them out,
things like that.
NICK: So like, Testdroid?
RICH: Yeah, you could try it
on Testdroid, get access to
some devices.
But yeah, I mean, you may test
it on one device and then a
firmware update will apply on
that device and it'll change
the SMS app.
It's going to be a tricky
thing to maintain.
ETIENNE: Kind of scary.
RICH: Yes.
I would try and avoid the need
to read all the previous
SMSes, if possible.
NICK: OK, we're just
about out of time.
So unless there's any burning
questions that people would
like to ask right now?
JOHAN: Well, I have a burning
question for a friend which
raised the question
in Moderator.
He's trying to achieve something
like Airplay on
Android, where he wants to play
audio from his the device
on a server he simply
implements himself.
So like the Bluetooth standard,
which overrides the
audio output to any device
listening on
Bluetooth as well.
Is there any way, or indication,
or does anybody
know about any tips about
playing via a Wi-Fi direct?
NICK: I don't quite understand
the question.
So you want to redirect all
sound output away from the
phone to another audio sync?
JOHAN: Yeah.
CHRIS: I doubt you
can do that.
YOSSI: You can do it if you're
using the Bluetooth headsets.
RICH: I would look at the
Bluetooth code and see what's
going on there.
But you'll probably
find there's
something secure in there.
YOSSI: On Jellybean you cannot
re-route all the audio.
But if you switch your phone
to mode "in communication,"
then it will think
you're in a call.
So basically all the input and
output voices, or audio will
go through the headsets.
JOHAN: OK, I've heard that.
Yeah, but still, he wants
to redirect the audio.
RICH: Yeah, it has to be
done in Audio Player.
Well, maybe not has to but
that's really where I'd start.
Have a look in the source,
if it is secure.
CHRIS: There's [INAUDIBLE]
and it's called Bubble Dna.
So have a look at that.
Try and look at the source,
because that does pretty much
what you're asking.
RICH: I don't know if
they use the custom
media player, though?
They use their own
media player?
CHRIS: They do.
But they do all the network
stuff as well.
JOHAN: Great, thanks.
NICK: Well, thanks for
joining us, everyone.
And we will see you same
time next week.